This is FRESH AIR I'm Terry Gross. Today we're continuing our series featuring some of
our favorite interviews of the year and the year when so many African-American parents
were worried that their son would become the next Trayvon Martin or Michael
Brown tunnel HASI coats wrote a book in the form of a letter to his teenage son.
It's titled Between the world and me and it draws on history as well as
personal experience to discuss the different forms of violence young African-Americans
are especially vulnerable to from all directions on the street in school
and from the police.
It won the National Book Award for nonfiction.
And this year Coats was the recipient of a MacArthur Genius Award cotes
was born in one thousand nine hundred five and grew up in West Baltimore where he
says everyone had lost a child somehow to the streets to jail to drugs
to guns coats as national correspondent for The Atlantic magazine
last year he wanted George Polk Award for his Atlanta cover story. The case for
reparations about the long history of what he calls white imposed
black disadvantage our interview was recorded in
July fantasy coats Welcome back to FRESH AIR. You
wrote this new book in response to the recent police shootings of African-American
people children and adults the book is addressed to your teenage son. So when
you were growing up in West Baltimore. What did the police mean to you
when you were your son's age.
They were another force.
So the two sided as you know it I don't want to be too cynical here. I you know I'm an American and so
I did understand them as representing you know some aspect of
the state that I was a part of some aspect of the
country that I was a part of but at the same time it was definitely another part of
me that basically recognized them as another
element within the society within the community with no
real moral do. Different from the crews in the gangs
and you know packs of folks who dispense violence throughout the name of the police who are not a force
to be negotiated. That could dispense
violence and you know I want to be really clear about that because when you're on the outside it's very easy to you
know label a group. You know a quote unquote gang as criminal but you know when you when you live in a neighborhood these are
people who you see who you talk to I mean everything does not always come the violence you can negotiate things you
know ways
of you know dealing with folks and I talk about that a little bit in the book and the police
in that respect very much the same way just like there's a you know there's certain
rules for how you deal with you know a certain Khuda lives in a certain place the police have certain rules for how
you negotiate them to if you want to avoid violence.
Did you ever see the police. Possibly protecting you
from violent forces within your own neighborhood.
Yes I did but I also saw the crews the same way you
know and I saw many you know my friends who would be labeled as criminals and in the same
way to question you know the for me was when do you call what you know I mean so somebody
breaks into your
house you would call the police again I don't want to you know be overly Senekal or you would call the
police but by the same token if you know you happen to be walking somewhere and five
people jumped on you and you know did some degree of violence you probably would not call police you might
call you know some of your cousins or you might call somebody a friend so it really depended
on what the case actually was.
You had a college friend you went to Howard University. I'm
in imprints Carmen Jones who was shot and killed by a policeman the policeman said it was
in self-defense after Jones tried to run him over in his jeep and you and everyone who
knew Prince Jones didn't believe that story. You write about this in
your book tell us a little bit about him.
I went to college with printed on it's very funny because when you when you write it becomes sort of
abstract for a while and then when people actually bought a suddenly becomes real
again I
went to college with friends. You know brass friends or great friends but he was someone who I
knew who spent time around who had you know just a great deal of affection
for Prince was tall probably about six four
slender beautiful beautiful man very very handsome extremely intelligent he was
from Texas he went to a magnet school in Texas for math and science statewide
magnet school as his mom explained he was the only African-American student
there and you know did the end of use for the book and talked to his mother Mabel Jones who lives
in the Philadelphia area now when I talk to what I realized was he was from a family.
Very very well to do family a
mother who had grown up in dirt poor poverty in opera Luce's Louisiana his folks
were sharecroppers who had you know basically worked a way out of poverty had become a
radiologist had gone to Ellis
you had served in the Navy and I've basically done everything America tells
you to do and had you know accumulated assets and some degree of
wealth and he was killed he was killed him he's executed like an
outlaw it was I was concerned the
offices were attempting to track down someone who they had believed had stolen a gun from
another officer. Somehow they got it in their head that the Jeep that
Prince was driving either belong to the guy who stole the gun or one of his
friends they ran the plates on the jeep the jeep came up with Prince's
mother's address in Prince's mother's
name. In Philadelphia they assume that this you know could possibly mean Adichie was stolen when in fact all it meant was
that his mother had bought it for him. They followed Prince Jones out from the suburbs
of Maryland where it went where they you know first began tracking
him into Washington D.C. and then out into Virginia where
they shot him with and you know feet of his fiance's
home thing about this that you know when I when I when I read it to my mind is this
the basic you know report from the off so what was that Prince had attempted to back up his Jeep
several times and ram the car that the officer was driving so he. He had to kill him he had to shoot
him because his life was in
danger but I tried to imagine myself in Prince's shoes.
If the officer who was trying and was not in a normal police cruiser The officer was not in uniform the
officer in fact testified that he pulled out his gun said police but did not never shoot
showed Prince's
bads the officer was dressed in an undercover disguise like he was supposed to be a drug
dealer and you know this is how insidious they get I have to imagine myself
followed from the suburbs of Maryland through D.C. out into
Virginia realizing. At some point that I'm being followed. Not having any idea that this is a
cop and having somebody pull a gun out on me and knowing that I'm near my fiance's
house so it always seemed to me perfectly
logical you know that Prince perceived that he was under threat.
Was it investigated. Yes it was nothing came of it was investigated
by the prosecutor's office out in Fairfax Virginia I
believe nothing ever came of there was an internal investigation by the Prince George's
County Police Department. The officer was not punished there was a civil suit
eventually with the way the office and the police department was found liable. But when I you
know was checking on that the officer was not suspended he had not been punished.
He had been previously found to have lied during another case and the lie was you know
so bad that the prosecutor's
office actually had to throw out every you know case in which this officer had
testified the Prince George's County Police Department was at that time under
federal consent decree they were being investigated The Washington Post did a series
of investigative Autozone on the Prince George's County Police Department around the time around two thousand and
one two thousand and two and found that they were more likely than any other police department in the
country to fired a gun
to the point that his mother made and I think this is actually
absolutely crucial crucial. According to the official record prints attempted to kill a
police officer. And that's how he died. So if according to the official record is actually
his fault. He's the. He's the one that actually instigated this that's the
last
word on his name which I just I just I mean that that is terrible it's just awful.
This happened nearly fifteen years ago when it happened what impact it has on you.
And
I know you're at a funeral or memorial service at how I was a devastated me you
know lead to a totally devastated me a year later nine eleven
happened and I just I had no compassion. I had nine I was cold. I was actually
actually cold because they killed him. They killed him and no one was held accountable that they sent
the officer they put off so right back out on the street right back on to the force.
I couldn't believe it you know after that the conclusion I had to draw was that
this was a group of people you know who had been given in power by the state to use
lethal violence. And there was very very little chance that any of them would be punished.
And so should there be a mistake any sort of mistake with
me any sort of dispute in which I was killed or you know my son was
killed in general I could rest assured that no one would be held accountable. That's
very very different you know excuses people make this comparison between this and quote
unquote black on black violence or enable a neighbor
a violent would say you know if somebody in my neighborhood did some degree of violence and you know there
were recourse there were things that could be done and it was you know a mediation some some sort of
thing and sometimes you can might in fact be violent.
But there could be no mediation between me and a state you know I mean they killed Prince and I was
it was it in the story
nothing nothing. So given your personal
experience and having a friend who was shot and killed by an undercover police officer
who never presented as
bad never showed his identity put that in context
with the more. Media covered
recent shootings of African-Americans by police. What does that add up to in terms
of the message you're trying to
give your teenage son now about dealing with police.
I
don't know anything has changed in my mind like in terms of like how I talk to him.
There's a lot of reporting that you know depicts is though there's a wave going on you know an uptick
and events but I doubt it is actually an uptick more people paying attention but I've
been paying attention at least you know intently for the past fifteen
years even as I mentioned it like the media coverage because I think that's what's changed. That you know that you
know phones and the cell phones have led to media coverage and people are really watching
these
incidents over and over and over again and I think for people who haven't been directly
exposed to that kind of you know
police shooting Yeah you know ality it's it's
very educational.
It is it is and you know this thing that I had you know in my mind and I don't know that we're at this
point yet and you know and this is why I say I really haven't changed how I thought to myself my son.
There's a kind of evasion going on where in
people think about what the police did they say was a bad cop wife we had
body cameras maybe we could do something about that but there's very little
critique about why our police operate the way we operate in the first
place because accuracy alternately comes back to Americans themselves we've spent the
past you know roughly half a century or so growing increasingly
Draco nian stripping back you know people's rights in terms of how to deal with the criminal justice
system increasing the punitive nature of the criminal justice system once
people in the systems clutches all of that is brought to bear when
we think about each of these dust behind each of these is something else some sort of
policy some sort of decision I you know when Prince was killed. I actually did some
reporting around is that in P.G. County in Prince George's County because there had been so
many other cases like
that you know I don't know if I get one I want to. Folks telling
me that Prince George's County. You know at that time was one of the most wealthy use on class
for African-Americans in the country and yet the police was one. One of the most
brutal police departments in the country. How could that possibly be true well you know many of the
citizens out next county have made the same sort of calculations that white citizens around this
country had made that great fear was a
crime you know and any sort of hint. Any sort of you know inkling of a
crime from their perspective the police would empowered to do whatever they wanted and so ultimately for me it's a
question of where the citizenry is it was not just a question of what the police officers are doing you know it's a question
of what policies. You know we decided to pass.
We've been talking about fear of the police and anger at the
police but you know part of your book is how you lived in fear when you were
your son's age when you were a teenager when you left the house
because there was a lot of violence in the neighborhood and you say basically everyone your
neighborhood seemed to be reacting out of fear.
You were afraid of other kids you afraid of your father's beatings you write when I was about our age each
day fully one third of my brain was concerned with who I was walking to school with a precise
number the manner of our walk in them or of times I smiled who are what I smile
that who offered a pound and who did
not so. I guess I'm interested
in what were some of the behaviors you had to
learn to protect yourself just like walking to school walking home from
school going to visit a friend.
Don't walk to school by yourself.
Make sure you have at least five or six people with you is very interesting when I bask in the Philadelphia seventy
six Allen Iverson when he came into the league.
There was always critique because he went everywhere with a posse and is always talk about policy while an arse.
And I immediately understood you know I did as a matter of physical safety for many years are
trained not to go you know into places that you don't know Bob.
Yourself getting back to those rules don't go to certain neighborhoods unless you
know somebody over the last you know your grandmother's D.L.'s you've got a cousin them unless you've got a really really
close friend there and you have a girlfriend in another neighborhood you need to go with four or five
or six other
people guys need to be prepared and you know you need to you know be watching
out when you walk through the street as my dad had my dad telling me just right now walk like you have
someplace to be keep aware you know keep your head on a swivel make sure you're looking you know
everything. Little things like understanding that I think about this all the
time that like the first really warm day of the spring or the summer when you're in
school is actually a really really dangerous day for
you because only a lot of kids out and people are going to you know be feeling a certain way and it's quite
likely that you know some amount of violence might occur and so you need to keep your eyes out on those
particular
days thinking a lot about which way you want to walk. You know it's just particular
to my middle school I think about this all the time you know did you want to walk down the hill should you walk up the
hill. So you take a long Securitas route as I would sometimes you know through the neighborhood
with other friends from those neighborhoods. So that you avoid certain people at certain times because they're you
know already home by
dent. There's a laundry list. You know I can remember having
you know like like lunchtime.
You know you might have a problem with somebody or somebody might have a problem which is so you
say well I'm not going to lunch today I'm going to you know spent my lunch break in the library which is what I would do
sometimes because you don't want to get caught with certain folks and then is the more insidious aspect
of it which is this my. Disposition is not you know to the street at all you
know I was not anybody who knew me you know growing up with would tell you there was
nothing. Street about me at all but you know what are things I
learned within my first year in middle school because middle school when you really started indoctrinated into
this
stuff is that any sort of a physically you know violent
threat made to has to be responded to with force. You just I mean you just you can't
tolerate any. You know anybody you know attempting to threaten or intimidate your body
you must respond with
force this I mean this had real repercussions I mean you know I go to
school night great year in my high school you know and I you know I got suspended for threatening a
teacher. You know ask you about that because you refer to that in your in your new book and
I don't feel like I understand why that happened. What did you say about my judgment
or fact.
I felt like he disrespected me you know that I mean I was I didn't
want. He yelled at me in front of the class by really really loudly
and again I mean this was the sort of thing that you. You know you can
tolerate you know they don't like teachers do sometimes
I know I know but he sounds like you're laughing because like it's funny if you've never been in
the environment I and I thought you have a great dignity that's all that's all you have I mean you know
teachers yell loudly at kids from time to time you're exactly right.
But if you live in an environment. You know if you're from a place where all you have is
like the basic you know sort of physical respect you will talk to me in a respectful way you don't have anything else
to lean
on that's very serious. That's really really really
serious you know. If somebody yelled at me now I probably would you know I you know sort of walk
away and live well I've accumulated certain things I have certain things I have a family you know I feel you
know great personal value in myself and in my work and what I what I do I
feel you know deeply loved by everyone around me I don't feel like I live in a particularly
violent environment I wouldn't perceive being yelled at you know as necessarily communicating to
other people around me that that they too could disrespect me at any
moment. So you threaten the teacher and then your rest is like
what I read about what did you say
and sometimes like you know if you say some like that to me again I'm a knock you out it was it was something but it was a
physical threat. Well. OK and I and in that moment I was not like it was not idle either I was very angry.
I was really angry. So who called the police
the teacher that he did that we had school police. We had school. OK yeah.
Yeah he called the police the teacher called the police police
came and I probably as I recall that I got into some sort of verbal thing with the
police
to the police handcuffed me and told me downstairs.
They call my parents they wrote him arrested for what and everything eventually I think of
me released me and sent me home by myself to my
parents and I She says I hate saying this.
Or maybe add this is just what happened OK and I wrote the book so and I've written a book about this without That's the
public record they released me I went oh my dad kicked my
butt
and that was the moment you know where Like I've said this several times and he says to my mom and I
see this
clearly you know my mom was really you know upset and I never really been upset about you know my
dad dealing our physical discipline my mom would be a lot physical despite my mom because I mean you
know so but it really upset my mom the sight of it you know I was fourteen and you
know you know becoming a big kid by
then and she tried to stop him and he said to her you know either I can do it or the police.
And so I go through this thing in the book about fear and what I understand
now and it's no make it OK and this doesn't mean it is what I would do but what
I understand now is how deeply
afraid my parents were when they heard I got arrested. I remember my mom later you know at
all if you know blood maybe like couple hours later that same day talking to me about it just like crying.
I just breaking down and
crying and they are there African-American families you know around this country
a large large number of Africa that just operate out of complete fear the day kids
are going to be taken from them and will do anything you know to prevent that.
You describe how when you were young your father beat you and sometimes he beat you for
getting into trouble like when you threatened your teacher after your teacher hollered at
you in what you saw as a very Millie ating way in front of the
class but your father also beat you once for not standing up to the person who
stole something from you and you felt like. OK he's beating me for being violent he's being you know for
speaking violently speaking beating me for not being violent
enough but you understood that he was also beating you because he said to you
if it's either me or the police and he was beating you in a way that he hoped would kind
of discipline you and protect you from getting into bigger trouble.
So that's how you were raised. What about raising your son would you would you hit him would you
take off your belt and hit him with that like like you were raised.
So in fairness to my dad I should say my mom and my dad. It was it was not the case that my mom
did not you know hit me either.
I saw his father sometimes take the boy you know take all of us you don't think that is blame to be doled out.
Yeah I have hit my son before I can count. I believe when I'm
thinking of him now I think three
times I think three times in his life I mean I would never hit him what would an object I've never had
and what about
I had a pretty big hole in my house
about disrespect and I say had because he's so old now that we're pretty much
past all of us. I had a pic pretty big rule in my house about disrespect and by which I mean
maybe this you know. Having this conversation with you maybe this you know he's back to something really old but I
wanted him to talk to his mother in a certain
way and I wanted him to talk to me in a certain way and I wanted him to talk to adults in a certain
way and I wanted to communicate that to him like it was like the big
big thing in my house now.
I recently had a conversation with him I was twenty four when Smart was one of my
most twenty
three and you know again your kids are born you have all of this great sort
of fear. I had him you know three three times three maybe four times
and his life but I told him recently that if I had to do again and if I had a kid right now I
would resolve not to have a kid at
all you know I just want to change why wouldn't you
know.
Because I don't be OK and I do know that when he when. I was a
kid and I thought you might go out and disrespect somebody and you get shot like that was what was in my head
you know I mean like you mouth off at a police officer and you know he get the you know the hell beat out like that was what was
in my head.
You know it wasn't just I'm personally offended by how you talk now you disrespect somebody's
brother is dangerous out here for you it is dangerous out here for you and I have to communicate that
to you and I'm more confident maybe it's because I.
Well I guess there a couple things going on.
The first thing is I've seen how my son has has has has grown you know and I've seen how maybe things
that when he was younger I would have thought of as oh my God I gotta get this
out of you because if you continue like this you know until you're twenty This could be
a threat to your life. I can now see them as him
being a child. They say oh you're your child and this is what children do.
OK All right got
that the second thing is I to be quite honest with
you have raised my son largely around a different class of
people and I mean literal social class.
Who don't hit their kids by and
large and I do you have seen a kid to do to be honest with you all
sorts of things that would have you know you know just my head would explode if
some things. And they don't hit their kids and my initial reaction
is you know I'll show you know your daughter your mom and that was my mentor you crazy OK that's what your kids you know I'm here
doing X. Y. and
Z. but I've seen those kids now like I'm old enough now she knows kids go off to college
get straight out you know send those kids you know basically you know grow into adults and
mature and I think basically the parents were right the parents understood they were children doing you know some of
the
things that children did and I think you know from an African-American perspective you know what
folks hearing this would say was that yes but you know a lot of those children are white and they were they are a
lot of children are white and have more room to
do X. Y. and Z.. What asked true but when you accept that you kind of
bring me and justice to the child you put the injustice of the world you know I mean you say what we don't have
much room to do X. Y. and Z.. So I'm going to do this to
you my impression hearing you talk right now is that
because you're African-American and because you grew up
in West Baltimore in a neighborhood that
was often violent that the calculations that you have to do
in terms of getting along in the world raising your son
are more complicated. Maybe I'm just stating the
obvious no yes no no but I think I just there summarized everything I was trying to say so yeah they're
just more complicated than your white
counterparts. They are and they definitely are they definitely are they definitely
are I don't really know people. Well I knew I didn't know I knew I knew one one
one fathered I was this way but in general I didn't really know
people with that exception that came
home like had a bad day and then beat the hell out of their kids that was
not like the environment I was really raised around like I said I can think of one exception to
that by a lot I mean this
was the way folks dealt with their kids the way folks discipline their kids was the way all
of his discipline their kids the way they had been disciplined his kids the way their parents had been
disciplined as
kids people had this conversation now about you know
about a spanking and about beating about you know hitting children but I you know
I understand it like I said I would put my hands on my kid now. Now I would do it but I just
think it's really important to stand where that comes
from. What did you have to learn about loving your son as a father that was
different from how you were loved.
I had to learn not to be so I
thought I had to learn to not be so hard and I
had a wife and at that time apart know when some are I was born and for most of my
life a
partner who for whatever reason. Did not have to learn that and was very tender and
very very soft with him.
And I when I saw that for whatever reason I didn't process that is oh that's his mother she's
being that way I mediately wondered why wasn't I way you
know and I lay but I you know very very I'm very very much a laborer to be that way you know
to be softer to be you know affectionate you know to tell him you know a
little things little things to tell him I love you every night and a kiss him every night before
he went to bed. You know my parents love me is just not something that we did it was a manifested in
that way I learned
it from from from my spouse I learned it from my
wife and now as you know we enter in this period oh he's going on
fifteen and I can see that and I you know I I'm sad
like you know. I'm learning that this is not going to be fab and he's going to leave me one day I'm very
happy I did that you know because if anything ever happens to me off a bit anything
ever happens to him. It cannot be said that I did not make it clear to him every
day how much I
loved him
I kind of had to coach thank you so much for talking with us. Thank you so much
her kind of Hussey coaches a national correspondent for The Atlantic and author of
the book Between the world and
me.